from NBC News this is today predictably
the sussex's Manhattan drama was the
morning Show's headline news the
American obsession with the Royals
ostracized or not playing out on their
streets the tabloids here have their
views of course it's less a couple
hounded much more a couple of hypocrites
they've left New York now and left the
dust to settle on the varying versions
of the events of Tuesday night
it was at about 10 pm when Harry Megan
and her mother left the Ziegfeld
Ballroom in Manhattan with private
security they headed towards where they
were staying on the Upper East Side they
were then driven across 57th streets up
and down Franklin D Roosevelt East River
Drive and other streets for about an
hour and 15 minutes Sky News understands
the couple then entered the 19th
Precinct Police Station the first of
three times that night in an attempt to
lose the photographers
at 11 PM they left the police station in
a yellow taxi driving South on Park
Avenue before returning on the third
occasion they stayed for about 15
minutes and were then transferred into
an SUV which headed to their friend's
house we went a block we were blocked by
a trash truck and as we were blocked by
a trash truck people just came out of
nowhere with cameras and started
snapping pictures it was just like a
strobe light show right so I put down my
visor they were covering their face and
everything else
the takeaway from all this of course is
that as ever there are starkly different
accounts of what happened how near
catastrophic this really was it's
certainly true that New York's traffic
even at night gives ample opportunity
for photographers to do what Harry
resents what he fears so much but the
Eternal tension is of a couple who want
a private life in the public eye on
their terms Prince Harry has faced these
challenges since he was a young child
he's been in the public eye and will
continue to be in the public eye they
have to find the right balance
doing the things that are important to
them in a public role with the Privacy
that they crave
deeply intrusive or a situation they
helped to create
either way the context of course is the
tragedy of Harry's past Mark Stone Sky
News in New York